so when Rob riemann came to me and asked
me to address this conference number one
i was very proud and happy i know since
long the nexus institute i know the
incredible work it does since years i
know what incredible space of democratic
debate and of nurturing of European
values it is I know that Amsterdam is
the place thanks to rob remain his team
and the Nexus Institute of one of the
last real place of high level and free
debate and discussion on libera value so
I was very happy on the principle and
proud but I was happy also to accept his
proposal in order to try to understand
what was really happening in this
Kurdish scene in a sense it appeared as
a very tiny event who cares about the
Kurdish people betrayed since one
century on and on for me coming from
they're coming from Erbil coming from
the battlefields where I filmed
shoulder-to-shoulder of the valiant
peshmerga's it appeared to my eyes as a
big date as a real moment of the secret
calendar of the modern world sometimes
you have events
who look like huge events turning point
of civilization and they are not when
Roma was sucked by the Galax in 308 is
something before Christ the whole world
believed that it was the end of the
world it was not it was only the it was
a fake alert it was only the beginning
of the Roman Republic and the Roman
Empire
sometimes when the Greek are defeated in
keone by the Macedonians in 368 before
Christ or when the Macedonians are
defeated by the Romans in pitner you
don't know the code the people the with
direct witness of the event don't feed
it as a huge thing and it is it is a
turning point of the current
civilization when I saw about him and
when he asked me to deliver this address
my idea was to try to understand myself
and to try to share with you the reply
to the question if it is a sack of hama
or if it is a oniy if it is a big date
or not a big date of our modern calendar
my feeling was that this battle of
Kirkuk let's call it this way was and is
a real turning point in our world and
this was really despairing and
terrifying for those who had eyes to see
ears to hear and position to to feel the
real proportion of the situation more
serious at the same time when America
was laying down
and was silent keeping silent all their
countries began to speak and to shout
and so highly in such a strong way the
silence of America was covered by the
heavy voices of other actors by the
heavy voices of a bunch of countries
which I believed which we all believed
30 years ago that they were out of the
game all that they were actors of second
rank in the big world play and who
suddenly became the only speaking actors
so the second thing which appears at a
very moment was when America shut up
when America disappears in a sort of
pre-columbian nothingness the second
thing which appears which happens is
five ghost powers taking flesh again it
is like in the antiquity again like in
the gray in the Greek mythology the
Living Dead of the akhirin of the Styx
reeve Italy resurrecting reviving
themselves and fighting the newcomers
this is the sort of impression you can
have when you see this Orchestra of your
Dogon of a body of the ayatollahs of the
week mr. Putin protecting so strongly
and what is currently happening
Third Point is not only that they are
ghost empires or empires which we earn
accurately thought to be dead but we
well not because at the end of the day
why not why not a passion Empire why not
a strong Russia of course but the real
problem is not only that we were
mistaken not only that they are ghosts
but the real problem is that not to say
more they don't embody really the values
the liberal values the democratic values
none of them for which we are gathering
here under the umbrella of the Nexxus
Institute
you